one more thing before we go tonight
since this show began almost four years
ago I've really tried not to talk about
myself on the air or even use the
first-person pronoun the last thing this
country needs is more narcissism it's
not very interesting anyway people who
use the word I a lot tend to bore
everyone but themselves but tonight
we're gonna make an exception to that
rule we don't have much choice last week
the New York Times began working on a
story about where my family and I live
as a matter of journalism there is no
conceivable justification for a story
like that the paper is not alleging
we've done anything wrong and we haven't
you pay our taxes we like our neighbors
we've never had a dispute with anyone so
why is the New York Times doing a story
on the location of my family's house
well you know why to hurt us to injure
my wife and kids so that I will shut up
and stop disagreeing with them they
believe in force we've learned that two
years ago a left-wing journalist
publicized our home address in
Washington a group of screaming and Tifa
lunatics showed up while I was at work
they vandalized her home they threatened
my wife she called 9-1-1 while hiding in
a closet a few weeks later they showed
up again at our house for the next year
they sent letters to our home
threatening to kill us we tried to
ignore it it felt cowardly to sell our
home and leave we raised our kids there
in the neighborhood and we loved it but
in the end that's what we did we have
four children it just wasn't worth it
but the New York Times followed us the
paper has assigned a political activist
called Marie carpenter to write a story
about where we are now they've hired a
photographer called Tristan's Pinsky to
take pictures their story about where we
live is slated to run in the paper this
week editors there know exactly what
will happen to my family when it does
run I called them today and I told them
but they didn't care they hate my
politics they want this show off the air
if one of my children gets hurt because
of a story they wrote they won't
consider it collateral damage they know
it's the whole point of the exercise to
inflict pain on our family to terrorize
us to control what we say that's the
kind of people they are they'll deny
this of course they'll claim it's just
journalism just the facts
really
so how would Marie carpenter and his
photographer Tristan spin ski feel if we
told you where they live if we put
pictures of their homes on the air what
if we publicized the home address of
every one of the soulless robot editors
at the New York Times who was signed and
managed this incitement to violence
against my family what about the media
editor Jim Wynn Dolph we could do that
we know who they are would that qualify
as journalism we doubt they'd consider
it journalism they call it criminal
behavior if we did it and that tells you
everything